- It's on the house, Deshaun.
- [Together:] Hang in there.
- Poor guy’s life is a nightmare.
- [Sigh]
- I try to clean house, but the dirt runs deep here.
- The NFC East winner will be announced at the annual NFC Feast,
and it is likely to be a team with a losing record.
- What if a superteam…stole the NFC East spot?
- There’s technically nothing in the rule book that says you can’t.
- Delaware Clams, assemble.
- YOU WANT CMC TO JOIN FAKE TEAM?
It’s time for a recruiting montage.
- Yes, let's go.
- We’re looking for elite players.
- I'll go.
- Oh well, yeah.
- I’m in.
- It’s T.J. Hockenson, from the Lions. You guys came to ME.
- [Together:] OH RIGHT, RIGHT.
- Uh, do we have to include a Bengal?
- SNEAK A-ZAC!
- [Together:] AHHH!
- Heard y'all needed a coach!
- The goal is to seem so legit, they just hand us the trophy.
- ONE, TWO, THREE…
- [Together:] CLAM UP!
- End of part one.
- What is it?
Surprisingly great rates from State Farm!
Wait, doesn't everyone get this?
- Uhhhh...
- Whoa, who are these newcomers?
- Hello, I’m...BB Volt.
I hate children and following your dreams.
- Oh, God, I’m lying and I feel terrible about it.
-  Have we breached their security yet?
- LET US IN, COMPUTER!
- HACKING. INTO. MAINFRAME.
- Huh, well you have football jerseys so, sure, come in.
- OK, Younghoe. Go charm everyone.
- Upright, upright, upright.
- Hahaha!
- I like you!
- Backs, are you in position?
- DROPPING THE JAG TO GET THE BAG.
OH NO! MY LEG MAY OR MAY NOT BE CRAMPING.
My apologies, fantasy managers.
- Luckily, no one seems to be paying attention to James Robinson.
- Used to be the Connecticut Clams before Mean Spamtos sold us out!
- Clean exchange. Ready to run.
- Hello, NFC East!
- QUIET!
- RIVERA’S SO INSPIRING
- Last few weeks we’ve been hot. The Giants, us, the Clams, I guess?
- Ha, well we're 9-5! We played the Bengals and Jags and stuff!
Oh god, am I addicted to lying?
- And the winner of the division...
The Clams?!
- Look, I never doubted the ol’ Zac Pack here for a second.
- Wait...you NEVER doubted an NFC East team?
- That doesn’t seem right.
- They’re frauds!
- GET ‘EM!
- Yippee Younghoe, motherf--ker.
- JALEN, DON’T RUN—
- No, no, let him. He knows how.
- Whoa.
- Are you really going to attack me, feel-good story Alex Smith?
- No. Here, man.
- F--K THAT. I’LL HIT ALEX SMITH TO GET BACK IN THE DANCE.
- TEAMY, ATTACK.
- UNLEASH CLAMMY.
- TEAMY IS GETTING IT TOGETHER, RAWR!
- GURGLE GURGLE. CLAM NOISES.
- Hi, I’m Carson. I play for the Eagles.
- Are you sure you do?
- AHHHHH.
- Hey Clam Fam,
Clammy here to announce that you can buy
DELAWARE CLAMS shirts in the Bleacher Report shop.
Now you can wear something that will make you constantly have to explain
“Oh its a joke from a webseries.” So yeah, you’ll look pretty f--king cool.
AND if you all buy enough shirts, they will free me back into the ocean!!